here's CNN's Jim Acosta asking fauci
fauci's back through we're just wrapping
you up with like a whole bunch of BS at
once to just kind of tie this thing
together here's a cost to ask and fouchy
about Elon Musk
and the other thing I wanted to ask you
you know you've been vilified on the far
right I know you know that
um and we've seen Elon Musk tweet that
his pronouns uh he's the owner of
Twitter that his pronouns are prosecute
fouchy others and the GOP have talked
about arresting you and Prosecuting you
um for your handling of code what's your
response to that your response to musk
and what has that been like for your
family
well I mean there's no response to that
craziness Jim I mean prosecute me for
what what are they talking about I mean
I wish I could figure out what the heck
they were talking about I think they're
just going off the deep end well I got a
couple for you fauci we could prosecute
you for lying under oath uh for telling
people privately that they don't have to
mask and that they don't work while you
were publicly pushing for policy that
masks do work uh by basically making up
lockdowns the whole theory behind
lockdowns which was unproven and
untested and completely made up uh maybe
a little bit of that maybe the fact that
your NIH through ecohealth funded the
gain of function research at the Wuhan
lab could we prosecute you for that or
how about for just being a smug douche I
don't know if that's in the law anywhere
could one of you we don't have a legal
I'll get if any of you are legal experts
is is somehow if you're constantly a
smug douche can we
[Music]
thank you